hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of top 5 scar mods of the week
and cam and I have returned like God
what returns have the Jedi it's like a
Jedi like one of those Jedi's is always
coming back oh yeah I'm lonely over here
me uh yeah yeah sure sure I was sad and
all those other low emotions oh come on
come on what Lisa did a great job great
job fantastic job I will be honest Oh
like um we had a big summer party last
night
a little horse as a result of it much
liked one of your mods last week ah have
you been brewing that oh it's not of it
now
anyway saying we have brand new mods
this week none of them involving little
horsies let's get to mod number one
all right welcome to River Wood said
that everybody else on to Maude number
one which this week is Dragonborn
werewolf replace her player only layer
only we're really not for anyone else
for friends not for relatives no players
any of those rags II werewolves would
just be the same yeah they said Kevin is
not normally a werewolf is II know he
has actually managed to get through life
quite successfully as a normal coin
regular doesn't need it if anything
transforming into werewolf is kind of
like a downgrade yeah he would be
weakening him yeah yeah why would you do
that
never but I tell you why for a new mod
let's give it a go it will be Oh what
the hell and then out of nowhere
wow he's uh a little Godzilla there sees
moves that's pretty good
come here yeah die there you go pshh oh
wow he is like a tiny Godzilla cuz I
think they were supposed to be are
you're gonna look kind of like a dragon
new to say what does a mod creator say
about like why this mod exist
why is this why mods mother the idea is
behind having this is for Argonian
player character builds now have a more
immersive werewolf transformation I like
you but it just feel like you spent a
lot of time in the head which is nice
and high res the head looks great great
but then the rest of the body was like
God I I need to go bad expires just like
I got planned evening butterfly I shoved
that butt up - laughs oh god he didn't
hunt ha - no we're just upgraded
together in the end may well not be so
good if someone could make a mod where
you actually where will he can you just
turn it - Kevin don't be amazing no you
do not ah sad I've met someone if you
were not here to grow with this then you
can be perfect Kevin there it is
I'm really good at it there we shall see
haha is this a good there huh
hey Sam we're here at Rorke's Ted this
is real innocence I've got a great idea
we're a mini Godzilla that's fun yeah
let's be giant watch it shoot yeah
that's big enjoy the fit camera
Wow you got him pretty good Oh God
oh god what have we done what have we
done said I think what we've done is
genius but well I guess there's nothing
for it but to kill everybody oh my god
this chaos Oh feet
paint anyone else still alive uh house
oh my god Oh bite me there's a film
waiting to happen Godzilla vs. dragon Oh
No we die oh we felt her died
ha ha ha was it Dylan Amy weakness was
gravity maybe never know is he never
jumps sorry let me just punch this
chicken uh you're not in god mode oh
yeah Kevin's games a lot of mischief
this week I feel like they're the
leashes be led off but he's just jumping
around jumping around in his pan yeah
that's why you weren't here last this is
all I did last week went up to Scotland
to run around your path it is the great
thing I did ever
oh good punch many dragons attack I
think I think I hit one
you're worried about the werewolf
there's five dragons lady hahahaha wow
that's fantastic first fact I think we'd
win this fight you know there's there's
a screen show of your there you go there
is the oh this is awesome
haha figure you just flew through us
yeah we're literally one shotting
dragons a nice guy are you stepping on
them it's not how you're killing them I
have no idea how good sad
oh god it's what the people always want
why are we never done this before
Holy Mother of God beautiful honey ha ha
ha that is a white dove you yeah I'm
glad this guy's wearing that lone Club
look up I'm giant you're tiny
I think you want
all righty sad time for mod number two
we have come to wind hell even when it's
cold and this mod has a certain icy vibe
to it so yes this month this mother
mattoon it's me Ron's doom sickle a doom
sickle how'd you feel about popsicle
serve ice lollies as we call them ice
ice lollies I'm a big fan
my favorite thing is the flavour and
also the temperature what about the fact
that they're really made out of frost
salt and iron more hammers I always it
well the ones I've always had as a kid
growing up were made of those and either
this one has a real eye any bite tip
like when you left anythin you lick the
iron the more hammer at the end it's
awful all tongue sticks to it and fuzz
awful there yeah they were fun times
mehrunes dagon is the Daedric prince of
killing absolutely everyone pretty much
what he does yeah I'm gonna be
interested what his doom sickle is like
here it is my youth it's pretty looks
pretty tasty like the little face on it
yeah I like how he's gone to the trouble
of it's got one of those like outer
coatings and then a delicious ice cream
filling that's what makes it a sickle
you know really like cuz he calls it
into the mod crazy okay okay the
powerful Daedric prince mehrunes dagon
loves killing the innocent mortals but
there is one thing he loves more the
plains of oblivion cat very hot and so
to cool off a bit
he grabs a giant creamsicle oh and I
feel like that's maybe what it is okay
well see what it's big it she's huge
stunning looks pretty right
I like the face on it reminds me of the
monsters from the fifth element yes they
really do they kind of like work type
thing yeah uh hungry
try what push wow it's pretty powerful
oh yeah oh god what did he do I didn't
want to but I didn't want a bloody the
ice creams who you hit it was just easy
half of it the stick instead
oh no surf bandits Oh heaven I hate it
there
Oh neither groin they're hungry and
overheated yeah how cool you are
oh oh there it is there it is that was
awesome
oh that was all kinds of awesome Oh
yeah yeah he likes that one he like
someone a lot oh here yeah oh so much
easier one I know is it - oh I think
that one is my favorite yeah it's just
like Bosch just guillotine it down
straight from the top
Seb so you know how we envisioned
ourselves last boys yeah-ha-ha all the
ice cream company as well
thermic take that haha in the shin I'll
show you I don't know so this is why I
love sky rods cuz you can be a tiny
hahahahahaha a tiny warrior wielding at
a Daedric demonic ice cream
I'd murder a bunch of people yeah oh
he's quite slow oh he's got a giant
arrow through hide in the long grass
there you go she'll never see is here
look he got away did seem to work
oh my god amazing
all right so time for mod number three
which this week is called tan back nice
well we find tan back as one of note
we've made ourselves a blood vest get
this naturally that is such a gruesome
thing I love it what he did was he just
licked it once and I did it to his back
yeah I know it's very sticky yeah it's
almost like become surgically attached
to it yeah
all right let's let's go find this time
back character wolf skull cave sounds
lovely
hmm ah oh yeah Holly today we've been
saying no one's for you no hugs for you
just punch this one face blood punch you
might get a hug you're lucky no just a
punch service seems that and we maybe
didn't need to come in here actually
apparently time back is found outside
the cave so let's go find him don't we
need a torch I think I might've spotted
Emily I spotted him two areas I'm going
to go ahead Keep Watch
Oh brilliant so he's basically a
companion but it seems tough some ember
support commands look at him though turn
Berta he's heat this is a brand new it's
texture is brand-new yeah different from
all the vanilla and SaberCats
he's a bit frosty look at him ice rusty
because it's cold out here but he is the
best companion someone Kevin could need
because he will not affect our snake he
will not serve traps turn back comments
on situations and surroundings through
subtitled roars and growls wonderful he
has the custom texture like like you
said I just said we're a great hunter
like he is nice
was that his master in that tent back
there Oh laughs let's check it out uh oh
yeah yeah this is him I'm against this
I'm in my last hours I can't fight the
poison anymore whatever those bandits
got me with is eating me from the inside
out
ooh what an embarrassing way to die a
lot of - who's concerned I'm sorry I'm
sorry this is really about Oh doubt he
stuck by me through everything except
this except death his brothers died back
there the bandits hands it's so easy
anyone left I said best of the lot tell
my wives I love them how my wives I said
hello
I will tell your wives that how do we
get out of your town back no don't look
at him town back no time back you're in
the way move I said I hate the Thalmor
oh yeah everyone does yep so let's let's
take care let's take time back in here
and kill up the place killin hi
everybody
your life oh yes looks like I already go
stamped on your face Tess listen listen
turn back I want you to attack the
Fillmore wizard yeah get in there
use your giant piece I'll keep the
arrows off you oh he's doing great
he's doing great yeah buddy oh he's
already on it turn back is suffering I
got it how dare you her Oh fair he go
good boys handbag town back is dead
there we go there's no he's not he's
fine he's hurt just town back in the way
again sorry oh you could never be in the
way you're good ever bad though I Sam I
can ask you the ultimate question yeah
time back yeah or do over there uh still
driving bad I'm afraid yeah tampax great
now
okay everybody it's time for mod number
four which this week is familiar faces
and I said when I first saw this mod I
thought it sounded super awesome I'm not
actually tried it yet nope so let's all
walk through together new tan back with
uh I don't know we'll try we'll try we
need to find something in our inventory
called the portal stone so when you
stole the Lord that should appear portal
stone oil sign looks pretty stony and
pretty portly here we go crack it on
Canada quit or can't I Wow do we lose
our eyes on the way think we lost our
eyes don't need them this place is cool
now so if I just understand what this
mod is all about yeah as it allows you
to save your different characters and
display them in these particular rooms
kind of like creating a gallery yeah of
your various Skyrim people so you kind
of immortalize them forever and as you
place your save character inside each
one of these books yes it were yeah it
will add little things depending on like
trophies exactly so based on the things
you've done yes well I think this
particular cabin from today has been
wonderful so I think we should
immortalize him oh yes an item of the
Dragon Ball begin right here in writing
now oh this always happens when I write
books did it take the ice cream with a
screw with it thank God I never think
what was that my torch
I think what's your torch yeah it's
pretty scary that's kind of terrifying
huh I guess he has done a lot of killing
there's a lot of data there's many many
things is it taking everything out of
his inventory oh god I think so oh god
we could be here a while oh no there it
is exported character data yeah
and done what oh yeah God that took him
out of it
writing is hard yeah oh man that was
awesome and even the smoke in the book
like ah it tells you the details great
look at that that's amazing
immortalized Kevin Lord so powerful so
basically if you've got lots of
different characters that you've rolled
in Skyrim yeah and you can even
obviously import other people's saves I
said we haven't touched on the coolest
thing about this mod yet all right that
what is that what you can do is once
you've imported all of these different
saves if you've got my like multiple
saves you do that as well but you can
then re-import these characters back
into your save of Skyrim as an npc so as
a follower amazing one it can be at
maybe an enemy someone who is marriage
able anything you want
fantastic seven how about this run idea
let's make a save of Kevin van Nord
bailable for download yep and you guys
using this mod can immortalize him in
your Hall of Fame and then have them as
a follower do it do that send us photos
right of your characters and Kevin van
or together and we'll show the best ones
off next week's show all right step here
we are is Kevin van orc now there's what
right there is a complete basically do
skill no that's so majestic good so to
get this guy in our in our game we need
to read the book right open the book
ready where do you it's gone he's now in
our game I think and we wait soon Phalke
wreath oh god Sal Don I see it doom
cycle I said I know this man why that
dooms two girls kevin van doors not your
voice mail you brute try that you've
been a good friend that's the one yeah
definitely no follow me I wonder if he's
is epically powerful as he is where
where him I'm gonna say definitely Oh
God oh this is completed we're gonna get
lost in it
Oh God well Kevin's guys knock out of
course he did haha
Oh - oh my god I need someone who's that
that was over very quick I don't want
some more fishes and we better let's try
again let's try again do it Kevin
make us proud
oh my gosh so amazing good lord
oh my god
I I bow down to thee as do you no you
don't need to bow he's wearing his blood
vest again if you go I need to trade
some things do you have his entire
inventory all those weapons yeah that's
amazing
I love this mod set this mod incredible
this is like this is that this is what
cascara is obviously a single-player
game yeah but this adds that degree of
like some of the great multiplayer
things you get in games they'll be able
to share characters with your friends
that is that is awesome such a good idea
all right said Topher mod number five
we've had Kevin with us he's not wearing
very much we're armed our armor is
terrible though anyway we need to get
herself some new armor and that's
exactly what this final mod upstairs the
user requested user voting mod yeah and
what is it sir this is evil mastermind
armor the serb kevin van Ark is actually
never crafted in his light now he only
steals him he makes them pay the iron
price did an e/m I don't think he knows
how to Smith the things that we need I
don't know so we're gonna steal it
yeah let's just say let's use console
commands as well as smithing it you can
also find it you can yeah it there's a
guarded locked chest located east of the
night caller temple near dawn star come
on Kevin cat catch up right Kevin you
can you can try it on first stopped what
is it because your cuz it would address
yourself you fool awesome
look at him let's go yep that is really
fantastic although he does only have one
eye whole little weapon is that
ridiculous you don't require depth
perception love the desert is jaw pops
out the bottom yeah yeah oh so it does
interestingly kevin vanden or it is
taller than kevin van org yeah i really
love it when you get armors that look
like they've been created from scratch
you know rather than just in
reinterpretations and reimagining so
absolutely right into the boots we
haven't really look at the boots we
never look at the boots the boots are
pretty spectacular as well it's all this
engraving on all the guards at work and
are on the buckles very nice leather
buckles dragon engraving on each of them
yeah yeah oh no it's a snake that's Nick
it's a snake this is actually one of the
most popular armor mods on the Nexus I
think of also yeah this is huge that the
mask has a hood built-in or you can have
it without the mask ah yeah for Kevin
van Ark oh yeah although it does make
his little silly is pick out the sides
oh it does oh damn you silly years
Kevin van Ark has finally met his hero
that's the only thing left to do is to
join with him in the fabled chicken
explosion alright the great climbers the
best of course that's what it was about
yeah it was a time back no we're gonna
let Kevin James Kevin Kevin this is
Kevin's task I need you to do something
I was your favorite thing it's your
favorite thing in the world kill killin
mannequin let's do it he's on it
go on go on Kevin get the chicken set
Sam it's going to save get the chicken
Kevin fine fine have it that one oh is
that good ha ha ha
what what sitting down backed it in the
end
Wow there we go I want to get this with
a pickaxe amazing did he get the wheel
to pick ax he wanted a pickaxe and a
Zack gun oh well sometimes that's where
you got a deer right yeah forget exactly
ow ow ow Oh got off the trees good thing
he's got this nice strong armor well I
think the most important thing we
learned today the most important thing
despite the beginning and the shrinking
and the tan beckoning is that you can
now have Kevin as a follower in your
Skyrim save yeah I can't wait to see
like please do send us send us screen
grabs of like your character and Kevin
vine Lord but doing stuff that'd be
amazing hanging out yeah things making
wherever you want as well like we've
given you as a blank naked canvas as it
were we've provided you that yoy and we
provided you the paint you must wheels
are exactly exact second wait to see
them but you know what until next week
when hopefully we have loads of those
we've had loads of questions and
comments as always huh
so let's get through them so Seb what's
our first question or comment who's it
from well the first one is from I love
motorbikes great name it's cute very
descriptive also from YouTube saying is
it just me
what did anyone else notice that her
head that's Lucy from ah speak her head
is so small compared to Sam's head no I
haven't noticed that do I haven't have
normally large head as many of normal
things about you 7 I don't think your
head is one of them well we did get a
lot of comments about Lucy from last
week yeah I mean you guys really liked
it what pains pains me to admit and
could I missed I was so weird not being
on the show but she did a great job
she Lucy's hilarious and we're gonna
have her lately she's gonna have doing
her own show soon and everything she's
gonna be on GameSpot loads so if you
like Lucy
do not worry and she'll be back at the
shorts and she will sure yeah well maybe
I'll relinquish my seat yeah yeah cam
Lucy that'd be great
the only ham Lucy combination wo the old
cam Lucy yeah well this Easter with us
like years ago I didn't it me and Lucy
presenting some stuff together I think
maybe possibly who knows anyway next
question this is from
lamb chops in late lamb chops in brainy
says this is on gamespot the growth /
sorry the shrink / growth raise need to
become a staple of this show like the
blaster and exploding chickens those
things are goddamn amazing like my life
has become better just by knowing they
exist Lambs chopping I completely agree
Oh fantastic we didn't use them this
week but we did grow and shrink
ourselves not yeah well so that's not
far off there we go yeah they will
definitely be sticking around because
they are just too much fun to let go of
the next one comes from sinus one on
Twitter says both of you have very good
teeth I love the show a little bit more
just because of that there are Lucy yeah
yourself and Lucy rocking the teeth oh I
do have very good teeth good smelling of
these very nice yeah you're welcome
okay thank you who's next we've got bah
dee four to zero presumably a rubra
thought it was her second row broke
through a robot robot yeah okay robot
robot yeah he said that dude looks like
the Brit version of Ferris Bueller Seb
you've heard that before I get that
approximately once a month yeah pretty
good and they were like I've even had
one time where someone goes you look
like someone I might like as Matthew
Broderick isn't it they're like no no
it's not here mark Matthew Broderick is
he mean they're like no no Ferris
Bueller like that is about you I don't
know know him Inspector Gadget hey guy
ah that sounds like a painful
conversation Roberts mother's mother's
three the third but as he's he's the OL
Ivor stead deserves but not the one it
needs which was followed up by a Matthew
canape says yes yes well I'm taking this
one yes but I have a feeling this is
going to turn into the high king of
Skyrim sued all over again now lots and
lots of dead civilians that didn't do
what Kevin said to do that is true
pretty much generally how it goes yeah
Kevin did make a great leader in the
sense that he brought pain and justice
and he led through the power of fear not
love good I'm glad that when I was away
Kevin was still his old self of course
he was course he was but that leads us
smoothly on two yes votes the vote and
we exactly neglecting the vote quite a
lot of late so I'm glad the vote is here
once again as always always like to
remind that every vote we put up for
every mod we put up for the vote has
been recommended yes are you guys very
much for that thank you very much and
the first one this week we vote on is
called Northern Cardinal some kind of
boot mod yes pretty interesting yeah
yeah it's more to be done on that and
the whip cane is up next tight so where
I gather this was suggested off the back
of having a Wonder Woman's woman no come
on guys there we go happy for you though
the whip cane and then lastly is a
little estranged for strange that's a
branch mod Bellis a Bellatrix Lestrange
from harry potter so if you remember
your harry potter law well there you go
i do what happened to I go and try and
break into her voltage high voice
rubbish everybody's rubbish Lily Brooke
I don't like runner you're breaking my
heart with me right breaking my heart
it's not rubbish oh great okay well
either way either way whether you like
Harry Potter or not you can vote on
those by going to tinyurl.com forward
slash ready semi blog did and as always
we will update the vote link from there
so go there lay down your vote we want
to know fantastic alright said well
that's pretty much all we have time for
in this week's modding extravaganza it
was late for those of you watching on it
worth it I hope because that was a lot
of fun it's great to be back I do miss
it like it it's a solid part of my week
but I can rely on I know I'm gonna sit
down please go with you have a laugh
kill a bunch of people usual and you
know just celebrates heaven being
awesome I miss you despite the fact that
I sit next to you every single day I
miss you good well obviously I'm pretty
great but guys what I'm really excited
about as well as sickness to serve is
seeing these pictures of Kevin and your
characters so send them to us what's the
best way to do that probably Twitter I
just mentioned that yeah yeah Twitter
I'd be at count four as Rob yeah I'm at
Ready Steady Go
are you just using hashtag GS Skyrim do
that and that way you'll definitely see
them and also send us any other
questions and comments that way too
fantastic well said thank you very much
it's great to be back
good times had and we'll see you guys
all and next week
you